when I teach I tell the students on the
first day I'm not your teacher your
teacher is gonna be Plato and Aristotle
and Aquinas and Khan get some really
good teachers of semester
wouldn't that be presumptuous for me and
I said I'm gonna teach you philosophy
and not appeal to the best that's been
thought and said I don't know what they
knew
science is one of the best avenues to
pursue truth for me I didn't realize how
much I would learn as a student in
courses outside of my discipline and now
that I'm here being on the other side of
the desk it's really important for me to
make sure students in other parts of
campus understand how important the
sciences are in the liberal arts the
liberal arts really are meant to
liberate us from the things of this
world so we're not so caught up in this
specific moment or this generation but
it allows us to see across time we
believe there are truths we can't always
know them perfectly but we have to
pursue it and whether it's the pursuit
of happiness as the Declaration or the
pursuit of truth in academia I think
it's critical that students recognize
that so much of what we do in education
is movement towards something it's not
always arriving at the exact answer but
asking the right questions those are the
kinds of things I think with truth that
we're trying to pursue
the Hillsdale there is an attempt to
understand the truth what is truth by
studying the great works of philosophy
of the past the great works of religion
the great works of literature in Spanish
for example we study the great
playwrights of the 17th century and they
are exploring what does it mean to live
a life dedicated to truth